Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: I used
to write everything with an Oscar speech planned
and that Oscar speech it wasn't who I
was going to thank, it was who I hated.
Film Courage: How did fear of success
almost ruin your writing career?
Tony: Oh fear of success ruins
my writing career every day.
There's multiple fears, there's fear
of success, there's fear of failure
and I think I still self-sabotage
myself. I have to get into a world of
it's a weird world of delusion whereas I know
I'm writing the greatest thing ever told to man
and through all of human history except it's also
a piece of crap at the same time. I guess there's
there's fear of success and fear of failure yeah
it was I used to write everything with an Oscar
speech planned and and that Oscar speech was more
it wasn't who I was gonna think it was who I hated
and I was just going to tell I was going to bring
all my resentments out you know and it's silly and
it's absurd to think about but it would be fun
to do an Oscar speech but then you kind of look
at it and go yeah but would it be really fun to
go to the Oscars. But yeah fear fear of success
it's weird because I've had very minor success I
don't have a you know I don't feel like I have I
feel grateful for the success I've had but in my
very minor success it's sometimes it's a little
disconcerting or where it's just like oh crap yeah
that's out there for people to see oh and I forget
and but at the same time that's wonderful so
what a you know what a bourgeois problem that is
are you going go to Starbucks and pay with
two credit cards after this I'm gonna pay
with two credit cards I'm gonna ask for
water and I'm gonna put ice in it and I'm
gonna be like you're gonna have to take this
back and not put ice on this okay right yeah
Film Courage: Do you almost feel
guilty if things go well for you
what yes oh my god I have therapy tomorrow
too we're going to talk about all of this
I think a lot of that though it does have to do
with I grew up a Jehovah's Witness so there is
a lot of guilt in succeeding especially in the
entertainment industry there's a lot of there's
a lot of fear involved I'm working through that
actually constantly I'm working through the mud
the murk and the mud of growing up in a way
where I was supposed to be not part of this
world and I wasn't supposed to buy into any of
it and my whole life was supposed to be devoted
to the church so I've been out for many years but
it's still back there and it still comes up so
and not that my story is totally unique I think
a lot of people have a have a rough time with
it because especially you know where you come
from working class family and you know it's
my grandfather grandpa DuShane I you know he lived
a mile away from me in San Francisco in the last
five years of his life I stopped talking to him
because I would go over there and he'd he would
insult me for my choices insult me for writing
didn't understand why I didn't have a union job
like he had and it was constantly insulting
and I was and I'm like I have enough
of my own self-doubt I don't need to be put down
so much so I basically cut him off out of my life
and it was it's sad but I had to do it because
he wanted me to just be weighed down and plus
he doesn't understand there's not there's not a
lot of money coming in this is this is all an act
of faith but it's also not even an act of faith
it's a half two when you realize you're a writer
you have to write and it doesn't matter if
anything gets published and it doesn't matter it's
I'm a crappy person if I'm not actively writing
and in order to not be a crappy person in this
world I'm going to keep writing and then I'll
be nicer to be around so interesting so when you
see a student in one of your classes or a zooms
you know sort of relationship and you can tell
like this person has some talent it
just needs some refining but I'm seeing
they almost they feel guilty about like they
feel like shameful that they have talent
what do you do to help them sort of come out of
that or you don't you figure that's their own
process you don't want to rush it yeah I mean
there's great talented people that come through
I'm there to I'm there to help them with their
craft and I'm there to give them and to cheerlead
them but at the same time I'm also not their
therapist so if they if they have guilt if they
you know I could come back I can come in with hey
this is what hap this is what I've worked through
and this is and I usually and this is
what a lot of writers work through I'm
I get to you know I get to interview
best-selling authors all the time
and they always feel like they have imposter
syndrome they can have 22 best-selling books out
that blank page still scares the crap out of
them but the one thing that they have ahead of
the person that has never written a book is they
remember the 22 best sellers every blank page
scared the crap out of them and then it went to a
best seller so they know I remember this feeling
and I'm still going to do it and I think that's
essentially all writing is to just know that it
doesn't feel good for a while and then it feels
good here and there and then it doesn't feel good
and it's yeah I wish it was
sexier than that but it's not
and you said just jokingly you always feel shame
writing something why is that ah was was that a
Freudian slip I don't know if I don't always feel
shame I just think that there's just a feeling of
it's the working class in me it's the working
class family background it's why are my hands not
calloused and why are my joints not aching at the
end of the day where I've completely ruined the
tradition of the DuShanes I'm not monkey wrenching
under a car monkey wrenching with a with a light
felted pen and an illegal paper and you know you
can actually make money and a living doing this
how absurd is this it's so maybe maybe my joke was
probably more because I was hiding the fact that
I'm it's not it's just weird to be a writer
in from where I've grown up it's weird to do
anything that's not mechanical or you know has
has union has a you know very strong union that
so-called strong union that but I wasn't sure if
you meant to also exposing thoughts and things
about yourself that even if they aren't
really that you know controversial that
it's just you're letting people know your thought
process right so that shame I kind of don't have
because my philosophy is if it scares me it's
the right thing so I'll write things that scare
me I'll write things that I don't want anyone to
ever know about me in my life and but when I have
that feeling of oh my god nobody could ever know
this that's when I know I have to write it that's
that's when I know I have to go there and it's
just hilarious that once those things come out
people go I've I feel that way too and and it's
everyone is just like how did you write that
I can never write that but I feel the exact
same way so the the beauty of just going to
the scary places I think that's that's what I
don't enjoy it but I do it and when I'm when
I'm scared to do it I know I'm doing something
right I know I'm heading in a good direction.
Do you feel shame about writing?